see ya I feel that trailer was very I
feel like what well a lot of mainstream
domestic horror movies don't get is just
like how much power there is in not in
things being slow or things being still
or things being silent like I remember
watching the early early early marble
hornet shorts and the scariest things
happened when there was no audio where
you just saw the perspective of someone
going around their pitch black house and
seeing somebody something standing
outside then turning its head real fast
yeah yeah and that was with absolutely
no sound just the fact that it was
sewing great engrossing and so so
effective with absolute silence I feel
like that's something that is
underappreciated yeah and I mean the way
granted there is serious and they have
the luxury of doing this but they
executed it and thought well enough to
make it the sort of series that makes
you feel more sort of dready and
paranoid as time goes on so every little
moment counts you know it's like you
don't even necessarily have to have like
a really big one no because you're so
sort of fraught with the tone and you
know I think that's sort of an issue I
feel like there's a nice parallel there
um when you look at the haunts and stuff
because it's like you know it's like I
love universal but Universal is you know
it's a lot of pop outs you know it's a
lot of it's very much driven by pop outs
and cool scenes and then you go over to
something like uh you know if you take
the middle leap you go to something like
the Queen Mary and then you go further
you go to something like a loan or
something like you know one of these
more specialty houses that are you know
semi art installations um it's kind of a
nice parallel for that because American
Horror you know American domestic horror
can be kind of like a funhouse is kind
of like that like we jumped out at Jen
you know we're gonna keep going you know
and we're gonna jump out again they're
like x-men of scares where as you hop
over to some of the smaller ones and
some of the sort of more foreign ones
they know how to take their time and to
build dread like we've forgotten about
dread in in place of scares a little bit
at least and so you know to build dread
suspense and paranoia I mean it takes
time and it takes you know characters
you can at least slightly genuinely
identify with and just a lot of
especially like big-budget mainstream
horror movies don't get the chance to do
that mmm because it's like we gotta move
it along you know like this a lot of the
ones I've seen lately have been remakes
but just like that was this is just like
the poltergeist remake was like a bummer
because it was just like come on out on
to the next one to the next reference
out of the next scare on to the next set
piece we're not gonna let this breathe
as a movie we're not gonna let these
characters kind of breathe at all and
and you know I think that happens in
drones yeah and drones yeah um so I
think that happens in a lot of our at
least big-budget mainstream horror
movies is there like what we're spending
a lot of money so we better better by
the fanciest one you know yeah and you
know I feel like smaller ones get to
take more of their time and add a lot of
the sort of more out there fringy ones
you know yeah so sad yeah sorry was that
was that too long a bit of a diatribe no
you hit the nail on the head all right
as long as long as the parallel works
man but yeah no I mean that that that
shot in in in like the gallows trailer
like I do agree it's sort of like I
don't know if we have a few like what it
feels like Gil from The Simpsons trying
to sell a horror movie a little bit yeah
I am I'm kind of tired of especially for
found footage movies because the thing
about found footage movies to a lot of
them granted I haven't seen the gallows
and I haven't seen some of the more
recent ones but a lot of them especially
a lot of paranormal activities space
those like scary moments out so like if
you break them down on paper there may
only be like five or six scary set
pieces and a lot of the rest of it is
sort of just watching the drama and it
is you know compelling then you're into
it this is like the first paranormal
activity movie you're watching two
people kind of live their life that's
escalating further into chaos and you
know the the ghost moments are few and
far between so it's like I can sort of
see why on the one hand you would want
conserve your cool [ __ ] you know so that
it's like I feel like maybe back then it
still worked a little bit just to be
like no no we've got it um but we don't
want to show it to you all and so like
this why I kind of cut them some slack
for filming alternate scenes because
there will be trailers like I remember I
think paranormal activity 3 did this and
and the last exorcism maybe um arabia's
later than that they're they're found
footage movies I've seen where they will
show you certain things in the trailer
that are like wall that's super cool
like you know aa ghost act like you know
the ghost is picked that dude up or
something yeah and then those scenes
won't appear in the movie like a diff
like a variation of that scene so it's
like maybe it's the same location but
it's not the thing we showed you in the
trailer like they start doing that and
people get upset about it because it's
not the moment they were expecting but
I've come to cut them some slack because
I like that better than the audience
reaction shot yeah because it's like
okay we're not gonna give away our hand
here but we've we thought enough in
advance to go what's something else
scary we can do for the sake of the
trailer that doesn't that just like lose
the scare ya there there is something
preserved in the movie yeah and it's
like what I think about that can you
imagine like a comedy doing that where
they're entirely different jokes in the
final movie and they just use throwaway
jokes in the trailer it's like we don't
want that one we don't want to have a
really great joke spoiled in the trailer
so let's let's do new jokes and shoot
those just for the trailer I feel like
yes especially like will ferrell movies
like anchorman 2 like they had a holes
are in a cut where it literally as every
joke is different Wow so if they had
that many jokes I feel like they should
pitch the movie with that just yet just
take some of the extra jokes cuz
especially the movies that ride more on
absurd comments like you a pretty much
just plug them in as you please yeah cuz
I mean you watch the the delete Caesar
like the first anchorman it's like you
know Will Ferrell will do like 90
different takes of different like
exasperated like exclamations great
Odin's beard mighty hammer of Thor yeah
rock pot of coffee yes yeah you know
it's every scene and that was what it
was for like um like a funny people take
movie could could benefit great from
that
I run for narrow version like the
extended the extended scenes that were
on there were like 10 or 12 different
variations of what what the the
daughters boyfriend said when he walks
in and sees see Steve Carell with a
bunch of like unwrapped condoms II in
the final movie says dude teach me and
he has like a bunch of different lines
that's right that word like chosen from
for the final cut and I think one of
them was like do those boner pills
really work for you old guys or just
things like that yeah just use all those
different comments yeah and I mean like
that was we saw funny people this was
back when we were still allowed at like
a sneak preview screenings hmm and we
saw it like three times uh and each time
all of the jokes had had were different
and like whole story arcs were different
Wow um and that first cut we ever cited
such a bummer because the first cut we
saw was like perfect like it was right
in the middle it was like it was like he
promised it was like um like twice as
serious and sort of like heartfelt as
his other movies and three times as
funny is what he said I think oh ha feet
we just um not see Scott see Scott seat
draws these really adorable like lineups
of cast members from movies and there's
one where it's it's uh oh what what were
their names the mom and the kid and the
babadook from the babadook and he does
them in this very cute little style it
looks very storybook and Erica just
found his babadook apiece Sam and uh
send me that [ __ ] what's the mom's name
in the bob duke of the sam and oh i see
i remember the actress's name yeah I
will I will consult the internet but
yeah like funny people was such a
perfect movie the first time I signed he
was like I wanted to be twice as serious
and three times as funny as my other
movies and it really was like that first
cut was like emotionally at least a bit
complex like it wasn't just nails on the
head and you know you could see
everybody's
flicks and it was like it had a perfect
sort of melancholy sad the way a guy who
thinks he's dying would and like the
style of the movie communicated that
whereas in the later cuts it was like
lopsided mmm so it's more like telling
us he feels that way but not making us
feel it with the style the movie as much
the comedy is a lot more overt in the
new one or in the in the theatrical but
the the original cut it's like they had
a whole different opening it was like
the same scene I think they must have
just had a really long tape of them
prank calling somebody because they
pulled different moments out of that
scene who it was like each time I saw it
the scenes also contained more cuts so
like the first time the intro scene was
one long shot it was great and then they
had a bunch of early stand-up sequences
because it takes place in the stand-up
world saw the main cast like does a
stand-up and like those had more time in
space and like the bits were so much
better and so like that whole movie had
different jokes for the most part each
cut and and I was like the first cuts
jokes were all great and the movie had a
lot of nuance and then it kind of you
know got more conventionally funny from
there or at least a little more you know
sculpted by feedback and [ __ ] but you
know like that what were the better
jokes up and weren't in the movie like
what was the character of them I don't
remember I mean some of it some of it
was literally just like those moments in
the movie where they'll show the
different guys like doing a show so it's
just their routines yeah but like the
routines were more charming and more
funny and I mean each one was different
but they just they picked like blunter
jokes for the subsequent cuts whereas
these ones like weren't like flashy
comedy but they were fun and relatable
and you know yeah kind of off the beaten
path of like traditional material but
also like there's there's the scene
where he comes out of the club after
when he goes to the club when he after
he's found out he's terminal yeah you're
supposed to be um he doesn't deliver
like a super awkward depressed you know
stand up he goes on stage and does an
actual
Mormon since like he hasn't done
stand-up in a while so it's a surprised
everybody know my gosh ur like will give
you time and he just sort of does a bit
off the cuff but like like a stand-up
not it does not the awkwardness of like
a guy who's finds not having a meltdown
our breakdown stage you can tell like
because we've seen the prior scenes you
can see in his face he looks like he
doesn't he alright it's just like he's
not feeling great he's not feeling great
but he's not feeling I'm going to die
yeah it's not so blunt is that he's like
this guy may not be feeling great today
but he's still doing his routine like
he's still you know giving us the show
it's almost like that cut that that
other tape belongs in a cut where he's
not terminal yeah and so like he gives
he gives or this that wouldn't be the
first thing you would imagine is up with
him like maybe he just had a shitty day
and he's doing this comedy now but you
know it's like you can tell something's
a little bit wrong but he's still giving
an actual genuine performance then when
he meets Seth Rogen afterwards like you
know it's a very human scene there's not
a whole lot of sarcasm and then like
just just things that happen later on
the movie like he reads Eric the
complaints I heard in both subsequent
cuts I saw were like he comes off as
more of a dick hmm whereas in the
original one like he's still he still it
still allows him to get unreasonable but
it's not so far that you're like this
characters just a dick now you're like
okay I get I get how this problem
happened you know to these people like I
get how you know the worst parts of
their personalities amplified perhaps
and any of the things that it's just not
as blunt force so he's a little more
understandable in the original cut thony
is in the later ones and it's just it's
just not always like I am sad it's a
little more like I'm you know the
trouble it's a that more tired sigh in
the middle you know so it was just like
it was it was a much more nuanced
picture um but I feel like for movies
like that's like that's what those extra
jokes are for is like you know pinch
some of those out so that we get the
tone of the scene and the scenery but
you know don't necessarily give us the
exact you know think we're gonna see cuz
then you can sort of cheat not blowing
the surprise I feel like the
and then I think of you know what's the
power of making a movie that's so
different from the trailer and I feel
like you you can't do that with a
mainstream movie because you you you've
got a Cell what it's what's in you gotta
say on the box what's in the box yeah
you gotta do if you're if you're like
making some indie art hasem you can pull
like a like Michael Hannah keys funny
games where the trailer looks like this
is a conventional you know home invasion
slasher and then the movie is saying
[ __ ] you for wanting to come see a hyper
violent home invasion slasher I mean uh
I see the only time I feel like the big
at least the bigger studios will miss
advertise a movie is when they have sort
of they don't think it's gonna work and
they don't know they don't get the movie
itself yeah cuz like the gray is a
perfect example of that of what I sold
on punching walls instead of coming to
grips with death yeah it's so like I saw
the trailer and I will I will I will
fully admit you know the the silly
twelve-year-old and me went saw the
trailer would do Liam Neeson's gonna
punch wolves in the face nice like like
in an in a silly way I was like yeah
I'll go watch that and then I saw and I
was like this is much more not that
movie it's like much more sort of
existential and harrowing than that
movie you know and a lot of people were
disappointed that it wasn't that movie
and I got crammed into january i was
just like if you just advertise this
movie was even a modicum of just you
know how dramatic it is you know i think
you could have just done gradually put
that out in September I don't know
imagine how the edge was advertised back
in the day because that's another one
those movies where you know the box to
the edge the box are in the poster to
the edge looks like it's alec baldwin
and anthony hopkins going nuts in the
woods and crazy [ __ ] is going down
whereas the majority of the movie is
these guys having to try and be crafty
and you know dealing with their
interpersonal stuff and more character e
things yeah it's like the cover Jerry
just pulled up the image for what the
edges one sheet looked like and it's
alec baldwin Anthony Hopkins yelling
when it's like the point the movie is
and then go both got their teeth now
yeah something reals going on it's like
there's one like there's one there's one
action sequence it's basically them
being hunted by a bear for a bit as just
this kind of far-off threat but the main
problem is how they're trying to get
back to civilization and how they're
trying to deal with each other yeah yeah
I mean that's we'd have to look at the
trailer cuz cuz part of me thinks when
was this movie made it was like the 90s
okay I mostly it's like 97 you know I
was right okay right 97 maybe not then
cuz I cuz trailers have changed over
time and it's it's kind of fun to watch
and study them um because I you know I
feel like a movie like that could have
worked maybe really well in the 70s or
something like that when we weren't
afraid to advertise stuff that was just
wrong man yeah cuz like now see writer
yeah and it's you know and all those
there are a lot of movies from that era
that are you know very sort of
disconcerting and things just happen in
life is very I don't know I always get a
more existential vibe from the 70 but
like I feel like some of these survival
in the wild movies could have just sort
of breathed in that time because movies
were allowed to just unfold then and
this kind of what you're watching is
things unfold whereas now you know you
kind of have to advertise this like an
action flick because that's what we're
comfortable with you know not a lot of
movies get space to just unfold and evil
I saw I saw an article recently that was
basically like why every movie is the
same nowadays and it was basically
pointing out just like it feels like it
feels like before the past like maybe 10
or 15 years structure was just like an
option yeah nowadays traditional
structure is considered a requirement
and this article chalks it up to the
explosion of save the cat yeah man yeah
i mean i would definitely i if it if it
didn't see ya didn't start with robert
mckee story or if it didn't start with
George Lucas giving the shout out to
Joseph Campbell after the success of
Star Wars
that that Liberty Bell cracking rings
was really like thrown by safety cat
well yeah cuz after Star Wars after you
know just like you know he named Chuck
Joseph Campbell and it's like there were
a lot of that structured moving yeah but
there were a lot of movies that were
allowed to not be yeah you know and and
thinking back it's like he's grown up
during the 90s but from the 90 cinema
I've gone back for him from the things I
remember seeing you know there was still
like stuff still got funded if it was a
bit strange yeah you know and and
funding strange stuff his room and show
yeah and if I was still very mainstream
movie but it was it was heady yeah and
like Pleasantville it was a mainstream
movie but it was still hell yeah
Pleasantville hell you is my jam i love
that [ __ ] movie well and I I mean I
even went back and watched Candy Man
which like handyman is it's it's 90s as
[ __ ] but be my victim yeah and maybe
Todd and I'd always seen him just put up
with other slashers but I watched that
movie and I was like oh this is Clive
Barker though like this is this is
actually quite dark and it's it's kind
of you know at least probing things that
aren't in the most comfortable realms of
conversation you know I don't want to
totally butcher the history of candy man
cuz i can't really recite you some of
the story but like there's like a
slavery plot line or something in there
that you know and that's like very like
this it's not drive away from yeah it's
essential to the to the plot so you know
you could do that stuff on a on a
grander scale then for some reason and
now yeah originally it feels like the
nowadays it feels like slavery movies
are only allowed to have like kind of
two speeds where it's you know kind of a
you know it's your django and change
words like slavery is a bad thing but we
deal with it kind of like a cartoon
villain yeah and then you have 12 years
a slave which is like just know let's
let's get [ __ ] serious yeah but no
candy man is like one of the few movies
words like this specter of slavery is a
problem now yeah like it's it's
contemporary the specter of everything
that's disappoint of candy man in that
sense is like
no no the ghost of slavery is kind of
still haunting us and still sore
stalking America and still doing damage
this is a movie I should go back and
rewatch because I think I watched it
before I would have Clive Barker's even
been perceptive of that yeah Clive
Barker's movies always have a little bit
of a kind of a political edge to them
when you when you don't expect it and
they're all very moody in that way like
um what was it Nightbreed yeah yeah
nightbreed in a lot of ways if you read
in tonight breed it's about it's about a
guy coming you know in essence it's very
allegorical and it's about a guy coming
is about the experience of like coming
to grips with being gay in finding a gay
community kind of in the nightlife and
you know and dealing with just sort of
them the mainstream world coming into
like crack down on the gay community and
demonizing you for something you can't
help and you know Clive Barker's a gay
man yeah and he's a good gay man who
made that movie in the 80s when you know
it was like every president oh that's
right yeah the 90s that's right Madrid
was like 90's in fact i started watching
i was trying to watch a horror movie
every day during october and i watched i
think five [ __ ] ah but well October is
only six days long so you were okay and
it got most of it I just gotta get that
last you know 12 and did something teen
percent yes um no but I started watching
I've read because my friend worked on
the the recent you know like restored
director's cut he was an editor and uh
oh and so I was like to myself to you I
should I should watch this you know see
what my friend work done and just the
first I didn't get to finish in the
first thing I remember thinking was like
oh [ __ ] this is 90s as [ __ ] yeah I was
like in 8th David Cronenberg as the evil
psychiatrist yeah yes and you know not
90s in a bad way but it was like oh like
I can definitely tell a 90's movie from
um well I mean it it doesn't help that
like Clinton walks by in the background
of every shot also true this is like the
alien inside just like just stepping by
yeah but see like the thing about Clive
Barker is like Clive I get this is
there's something about like since he
comes from
sure yeah you know like he was writing
these things and and you know it's it's
a different becomes really think about
the format differently he always seems
like he onyx and uh video games with
clive barker's clive barker's jericho
derive barker I I still left that yeah
cuz everything is called Clive Barker's
but like he's one of those guys I think
has earned the wood the worth of putting
your name over like yeah does he know
apologize no was harsh but you know what
a Clive Barker's anything is yeah
exactly winces Clive Barker's [ __ ]
oral-b toothbrush you know that like you
know what to expect from this to this
will probably be you know sort of gothic
probably have like a sexuality about it
it'll be sort of like probing and in
sort of sacrilegious in some way like I
don't he's he's got enough of his own
you know aesthetic style that putting
Clive Barker's on you know I definitely
denotes a thing you know whereas if I
just put my name on something no know
what that means yeah well um your famous
deli is really popular that's true
that's true i don't think i am a good
indication of like the deli life like
you know sort of like giant sandwich
isn't you know like a bowling alley news
door like i'm not that yeah like all the
time to be like hey come on down to
jerry's like so it would still if it was
me my face people would be like I don't
know what this bars this this place
about probably be like some guy in the
corner spinning a vinyl record and yeah
and you know so we'll wore beards mmm
but yeah um yeah now climb burger I mean
like he is he's always felt a bit
separate to me from the rest of you like
the guys like Wes Craven or um tobe
Hooper or any of you know the different
you know sort of horror cinema directors
yes guys who made a lot of horror movies
like Clive Barker always seems like he's
always a little bit darker and a little
more I feel like barber stuff I feel
like Clive Barker and John Carpenter
kind of like complement each other
really well well cuz cuz Clive Barker's
almost like the more um the guy who's
kind of willing to say anything in
in a more aggressive where was I feel
like John Carpenter just kind of says it
like it is and with a shrug you know
with a shrug because he's a very you
know John Carpenter is a very sort of no
[ __ ] he's just kind of a guy yeah
you know and you get how why he would be
the author of these films but in a sort
of mellow sort of a kind of way yeah
like uh well I mean I guess you can make
the I don't know like compared to like
they live which is a very political but
also still in a very pulpy campy way
yeah oh I'm sorry I thought I thought
that was the beginning of sense no sigh
compare compare that to like Clive
Barker's type of output well yeah I mean
cuz Clive Barker wouldn't Clive Barker
would be puppy in a different way cuz
cuz something like I'm not all the drunk
arbiters movies have this but you know
um they live has a fun quality to it
even even though like you know that the
intrigue and the sort of threatening
parts do still feel threatening in that
environment like you know it still kind
of got a rhythm and you know an
absurdity whereas Clive Barker is much
more sort of gothic and you know
straight ahead about things and gets
melancholy yeah melancholy a little bit
you know markedly dark you know so it's
like hell raisers is deliberately paced
but it's also gonna show you some really
striking really bleak images you know
there's there's that character I think
in the first one that's just all exposed
muscle like oh isn't the first
Hellraiser yeah yeah skinless get out
then yeah really creepy bloody like a
very striking image yeah Joe and those
themes you know like you know that Santa
bites in hell and you know the sort of
synthesis of pleasure and pain and you
know Clive Barker's design sense is
really intense and really interesting
you don't see things kind of like that
anywhere else and i get i get excited i
guess maybe like todd mcfarlane designs
it's like I guitar which aren't they
don't have the same kind of like melon
like Todd McFarlane designs don't have
the same melancholy or that same
sexuality to them yeah when I feel like
why should I do part of that comes from
there some Tomic fairly things
like a lot of cheesecake to him yeah
what is the dip like what what separates
them okay so it's like is it like
certain light characters yeah like I
mean Clive Barker when he deals with
sexuality in horror and his imagery is
all like very like S&M themed and very
kind of it's all very um alien and kind
of uncomfortable whereas Todd McFarlane
when he deals with sexuality he will he
will just kind of combine gore with
things that are more like traditionally
sexy I saw a blunt odd McFerrin like
statuette where's like a sexed up Little
Red Riding Hood is you know looking like
a Playboy model holding the big bad wolf
was just like an actual wolf that's been
disemboweled and there's just a bunch of
entrails and a slimy grandma inside of
them okay so it's like the the gore is
there the grotesquerie is there but the
sexuality is not yeah is there but it's
not combined with in the same way as
like a clive barker thing well yeah it's
like a clive barker one is less lurid
and more not psychiatric but more like
any any sexuality that appears in a
clive barker movie isn't made to be like
oh yeah it is going to be alien yeah
it's usually meant to be alien or orange
more HR Giger all almost yeah you know
it's you know it's it appeals to the
darker side of your sexual desire I
guess you know and what that is it was
fun in clive barker's world yeah it's
almost like um like what HR Giger does
works like sexuality feels mechanical
and human and and dark and dark and
alien and like it's actually not like
it's something that's it's something
that's scary because it almost feels
like a HP Lovecraft elder god it's
something that's big and unknowable and
separate from you and possibly if not
sinister its goals are totally
unknowable and I think that's something
about cry like it's a markedly Clive
Barker thing with a lot it's like if
you're comparing Clive Barker and John
Carpenter it's like Clive burger has
very seems very like introspective or
the Nuggets that form those stories seem
like they would all be very personal and
and sort of you know dug up from his own
psychology whereas a John Carpenter
movie has it has a you know a similar
amount of insight but in a more outward
way it's sort of like you know you know
it's still processed through his
perception but it's more of like a you
know if you take something like they
live or I think even big troubles like
this it's like this is how I see this
thing you know this is how yeah one part
of the world or my father's flaying
himself apart inside out John
Carpenter's fleeing the world apart
outside in yeah and I mean they both
reach a relatable thing in the middle
cuz it's like you know is it Clive
Barker's flaying himself but in a way
where he's like you know opening it up
to to engage it with you so there's a
certain like it's still stark and it's
still uncomfortable but it's it's also
you're being guided through this world
like there's a certain not relatability
but it appeals to things that are kind
of simmering beneath all of the cert
like the surface of all of us whereas
John Carpenter is a little bit more like
bringing it down to a more relatable
level or at least like taking a more
relatable like point of view on things
totes relates yeah not liking it in like
it looks accessible but it's like I get
it like you know you're you're taking a
look at advertising and the sort of
insidiousness of free market capitalism
through this guy who's just a
construction worker man and a drifter
and a drifter and he's seen it kind of
like it is you know and we are waking up
with this guy in real time like it it
brings it to us whereas Clive Barker
kind of takes us down to a uncomfortable
place in it in a different way but
they're so both like kind of with you
you know during this experience unless
all of that sounds woefully up to some
nonsensical which case I mean it's like
how else are you gonna articulate stuff
like this cuz this so subject yeah any I
mean you don't oh you don't often if
discussing these things in that in that
light yeah but yeah it's like so Clive
Barker in terms of horror likes always
had a different you know corner like
Clive Barker is kind of a genre of those
to man it's and you know it doesn't now
imagine a clive barker haunt oh boy cuz
i imagine probably hurt but it would
probably be oddly sexual yeah i feel
like a clive barker haunt would have the
pace and the tone in the mood of a loan
but the imagery of like a horror nights
and well yeah and it would probably hurt
more hmm at some point cuz like yeah
there's always something there probably
kind of bleak and there's always
something else going on it's like i've
never seen a silly clive barker movie or
at least a silly like intentionally
silly oh my god I haven't seen it I
bored and unintentionally but I've never
seen one that's like hey mike Parker
remakes the jerk yeah exactly it's like
I can't imagine what that it would be
interesting uh and he seems like a
personable enough guy but you know it's
it's like where is the other a lot of
the other you know candy mans often
lumped in with slashers and stuff like
that but Candyman does not feel like
watching a Jason movie or freddy movie
or even a Michael Myers movie after a
certain point cuz it's also the Candyman
is incorporeal he's anywhere and
everywhere I guess the Candyman is also
more like the ring in that way where
it's haunting you but it's not physical
yeah and that's sort of that's not
necessarily like a very that's not as
American of a you know place to draw
from cuz a lot of japanese [ __ ] does
have that yeah sort of quality where
it's like a person being haunted by
something very specific and very almost
like spiritual yeah um and you can sort
of find out like there's like I saw
midnight meat train and you know you
hear a movie called midnight meat train
that stars Bradley Cooper and Vinnie
Jones I imagine it's about like Jesus
unlike guys working the graveyard shift
at a butcher shop in philly and and just
some some wacky [ __ ] that has to go on
it all takes place over the course of
one night that is not what this movie's
I know cuz it's like it's a horror movie
yeah I would watch that though hmm will
star in it midnight meat train goodnight
new track but I you know Jerry we gotta
movies hang out i get these these rob
roasts to crust mom Jerry my chick she's
pregnant I don't know what I'm gonna do
oh they gotta move this me that's
midnight meat train yeah it's like a lot
of mournful seeger playing over light
nytimes city skylines what it looks kind
of industrial it's just them both airing
out their woes and then both agreeing
that they can't do anything about it
right now cuz they got to move the meat
gotta move the meat it all takes place
on this one train and then it just
becomes a sad metaphor for the monotony
of life all of your most important
situations are elsewhere while you're
just moving the meat like that Tom Hardy
movie where he plays a construction
project manager and it all takes place
with him driving in his car Oh lock yeah
I wanted to see that I want to see it
too I want to see it a lot but tell me
what you were actually were gonna say
about the actual guide but then I mean
training like you hear the title and
you're like oh that sounds you know it
sounds like a schlocky like a you know
aggressive sort of like new metal in
your face you know slasher movie or
something like Bradley Cooper's got
cyber dreads maybe not that far but you
know like ah you know not that new metal
it may be something more long line if
like a jeepers creepers error movie
where is just like you know a lot of
people are gonna get on this train and
get slaughtered like oh yeah um uh and
ends you know some kind of lucky hero's
gonna you know unravel it like like you
could argue that it could go there but
then you see it you're like you know
Bradley Cooper plays a photographer and
he you know what's he doing on a train
he's not meet yeah and I don't know
there's something about that movie that
there's a lot more to it than just a
dude who slays people on the train at
night you know i mean there's that's a
part of it and there is some very you
know there is some gore there's always
gore in a clive barker movie but it's
not like bro igora it's not like super
polished high gloss studio gore it's you
know it's you know sort of stark and a
little in your face but there's also
like a very sort of dready sinister
thing going on underneath it so that's a
movie a lot of people saw and went oh
this is actually pretty good like this
is a pretty good movie like because it
didn't
get nearly the amount of you know i dog
sit on it and the netflix real a few
times yeah same Darren nah I didn't
realize it was a Clive Barker Rubio just
like oh it is this I may have seen it in
seen Clive Barker and thought oh it's
one of those Clive Barker presents type
things isn't it yeah no I mean this is
based on one of his stories yeah I mean
he hasn't directed all of his movies but
yeah dude you're at Jericho yes he did
and he'll play it with you online for
free well like Vin Diesel jock yeah I'm
his last witch hunter movie hey man if
this gets gay people interested in
Dungeons and Dragons yeah we we I was at
um I go to funny school yes um and I was
at my funny school class no I'm in the
conservatory at I have one of the name
improv theaters in in LA right now and I
was i I was in class today jamming with
with my cohort and we have one of the
one of the instructors and we ended up
chatting cuz he's apparently way into
Dungeons and Dragons yeah what you
wouldn't get because he just is he a
mage I don't know but he was like this
big because he doesn't seem like it what
you think of when you think dungeons dr
says he's like big brash you know
butterball you know loud guy okay was
like very you know out there and abrupt
and kind of like a force to be reckoned
with comedic lee ok you don't just
imagine a guy who's like that big and
confident to be way into Dungeons and
Dragons let's say way you don't exactly
expect Vin Diesel to be in dungeons into
Dungeons and Dragons yeah well I guess
if you're into improv and you're in like
dungeon if you're into Dungeons and
Dragons then improv is will bounce off
of that the same way it did for like um
Stephen Colbert just because or you know
with Vin Diesel it's like the
role-playing leads you into acting yeah
and I feel like maybe maybe uh maybe
improv you know sort of is more than
that Venn diagram than you think because
really improv is the larping of comedy
yeah so I imagine like a nerdy type who
might be inclined to play dungeons
dragons would probably be most inclined
to do in
prob improv the neurotic ones will do
stand-up and then the rest of us will do
sketch and the more methodical types
will do sketch improv improv is LARPing
for an audience yes it's larping the
people I really want to go participate
in yeah as we've done this we were in
probably the scene that was basically
like a bunch of kids that were waiting
to dungeons and dragons we're doing it
had to do community service for some
reason and I came by is like the angry
yard duty that was a good where do i use
shits fired a magic missile at the trash
cans by the locker room and then I was
like and you know it's like they got all
nervous I was like god they're magic
missiles so overpowered yeah he and the
instructor was he joked and like let it
be known that he knew in which editions
of Dungeons and Dragons magic missile
was actually overpowered in when it was
balanced oh that was hilarious to me so
you're getting towards the edge of where
I start losing the dnd references I so
cuz I'm associated but I saw that I just
go so Jason Bell yeah I just know it's a
spell one King cast did you know that
that was his fellow did you just throw
out a term I just heard I've heard magic
missile and I assumed well that sounds
like a very like baseline spell I just
assumed it was in like dungeon drivers
because I saw videos of I've seen videos
of kids larping and just looking
ridiculous in the woods and they use
like the fireworks to stand in for magic
spells sometimes in like one kid was
like firing off a little popper and just
saying magic missile as if he was
casting this firework I saw another one
with a kid throwing cardboard lightning
bolt to somebody and just shouting a
lightning bolt lightning bolt lightning
bolt he's throwing these long hardboard
lightning bolt said somebody I feel like
LARPing would be so much more accessible
to people if it just wasn't called
LARPing yeah because LARPing like a lot
a pretty word yeah is this kind of lumpy
and unpleasant and and it sounds like
the combination of certain like you know
bathroom words just like nebulous
bathroom yes LARPing like LARPing sounds
like you should be like barfing and
pooping at the same time like all do
youdo alarms all over my cashews
I got food poisoning LARPing ever like
it just it sounds unpleasant a little
bit and so like LARPing it doesn't help
you out as a word it's not a word you
know that yeah it's not doing you any
favors I get this an acronym but maybe
like you know it was interesting that
layer was was organized sword and sandal
Aang yeah it was interesting in in role
models layer being the fake LARPing
LARPing is ever they called it no they
called it was just called layer la I are
like live-action interactive role play
experience which is basically just like
lard boat with a fake acronym yeah so is
it was larva like an actual yeah live
action role play but is that an actual
like I somebody trademarked that
internal or official date okay I just
for whatever reason they used a fake
term for it in in role models
interesting yeah I'm not certain why
let's do this we shall thank you Joe
true Jojo literally I was watching I'm
wondering you Charlie Charlie who you
all will meet soon I was showing me some
episodes of the state this oh the state
and like holy Shi have you seen the
Louie wait which one's Louie he's the
guy who says this classic catch phrase
over and over yes oh [ __ ] what is it
what is it I want to dip my balls in it
he pulls out to actual ping pong balls I
was thinking of a different character
but yes I know exactly this is I
discovered a Louie it was just like
introduced every luby's get by like
celebrating how he's gonna say his
catchphrase and they just he's a guy
purchases I want to dip my balls in it
this country's absolutely absurd he was
on a pair of ping-pong balls oh man why
is this ryan and i just watched the
Christmas episode of Bojack horseman
again oh boy and was rhyming like Bojack
where he had never he hadn't really seen
it and so um we were doing like the
maiden voyage of a we're doing like the
first episode of something were starting
up and or we were asked to participate
in that basically you have to watch
something on Netflix uh-huh so it was
like it was like I know you're
interested in
I've only seen the first couple episodes
and this is an isolated one so we won't
have to worry about like demon whole
season blah blah blah or at least
creating that misconception so is this
like let's for the maiden voyage let's
do something contained so he watched the
Christmas special and it made me think
of that too is just like his his
catchphrase that just won't happen
though brother Chou sawaz of Bobo's yeah
yeah the one reject kid and just the one
dude in the back of the audience who's
always yelling out like the worst thing
the worst thing and the like exact
intended desire of whatever line he's
just reacting to you he just did the
thing said he was a good or two earlier
yes like I and it's just playing on the
same thing it's just like I'm gonna dip
my balls in that just like here's a
really stupid catchphrase and and like
Rick and Morty does that do is is that
with Wubba lubba dub dub what is that
it's Rick's catchphrase which we then
learn is is not actually a Joyce
catchphrases oh it's an omission it's
it's in a different language and it is
the admission of great pain oh [ __ ] um
it is a bird person explains that in one
episode he's like know what beloved dub
dub is actually in the language of my
people and it means help me I am in
great pain oh girl like so it's like an
actual kind of sad moment there yeah I
would dip my balls like yeah so from
guns to alone ya know is gonna it was
gonna wrap back around and then to Clive
Barker how got into Clive Barker we were
talking about found footage trailers
yeah and then we sort of got into jokes
and we gotta this Jukes Jukes ya know
well let's trace it back this day put my
balls at him put my balls in the state
in Clive Barker how do we get on the
catchphrase conversation from the state
okay but before then why did we get on
this day I don't know Oh Oh Joely truly
a larper here okay uh
no cuz at a point I was gonna make it
was somewhere buried in one of the
earlier arguments no I think um because
say I think saved the cat I mean I don't
remember when it came out exactly like
two thousand five or maybe even before I
feel like the first edition asst I think
I was earlier than that yeah maybe even
because if you look at the way movies
started to go around that time is when
we started having every movie be Joseph
Campbell or being you know the hero's
journey this structure yeah the like
less movies a Hollywood version of
Joseph Campbell which is not as exactly
the monomyth yeah uh but you know the
Hollywood standard you know save the cat
now is it's you know now is the most
recent version you know that structure
it's like you can sort of see that shift
i think away from movies that maybe
don't have them yeah so like now the
only person who can get a big-budget
movie made that doesn't follow that kind
of a structure is usually quentin
tarantino yeah somebody who was
established as a still marketable otter
before that that axe fell yeah exactly
it's like quentin tarantino movies like
they don't follow that structure but
yeah he's done that he doesn't follow
that structure every time and sometimes
it's like you know Quentin Tarantino
will follow his own structure which is
fine but i will say that at times like
there are things in quentin tarantino
movies i feel like they're a little bit
baggy yeah yeah the very last leg of
django unchained felt like it felt like
it dragged a little bit the whole bit
with the Australians yeah yeah I get the
argument about Django because everyone's
like it should have ended the first time
we shouldn't have to have him go back
and and you know it should have ended
somewhere you know close to you know
once they've basically been found out
and they're they're about to leave
Candyland it's like that's where it kind
of should have ended like after that
whole shootout and stuff like down but
it's like yeah for the from the thrill
and for the satisfaction of like a movie
experience then yeah but that I guess
that's the problem with that movie
structures he has to go back alone yeah
and do all that alone select the last
half of the movie or the last you know
chunk of them yeah is necessary yeah you
need that whole thing of you know genco
not
having is because I mean though the
Django Unchained suffers from white
Savior complex really badly and so it's
like to at the very least make up for
that a little bit you have to have
Django go without his his white Savior
yeah yeah and so like you know some of
his movies fall into that you know which
i think is definitely a structural thing
but some of them you know do just fight
like there are far less visible
blemishes without a more traditional
structure you know but I feel like you
can sort of start to chart that because
around around the time save the cat
started to hit I think we did sort of
gravitate towards just movies that
weren't necessarily act because in the
90s you still had movies that didn't
necessarily seem like the standard I
mean they probably shared certain
standard beads they weren't like all
super out there but you know just it
didn't seem like things were as beholden
until save the cat really started to ten
hit and it feels like in past movies you
they even if they did hit those beats
they hit those beats really differently
like I remember the matrix I don't room
and I as I think about is like now the
matrix more or less follows that plot
but it hits every beat differently than
how you think it would yeah then like a
movie today would hit those same beats
yeah and I mean like there's there's an
awful lot of stuff in the middle of the
matrix that's just talking yeah that
isn't like you know obligatory action
sequences when and and and you know the
amount of there are apology there are
big obligatory action sequences but
they're not in the order that you would
expect with today's structure yeah and I
mean you get their relevance based on
film history and and you know the kind
of story it is but like I think also
this the level of psychology you put
into the writing you know just which
isn't necessarily like a you know it's
not necessarily like a structural
prowess but I feel like if you take that
structure and fill it with a lot of life
that can make up for the structure
because now it's there's something to
think about something to connect to
around it ironically i just remembered
the matrix was another movie where the
writers name check joseph campbell but
that's interesting does they named check
to Joseph Campbell that means they
probably they probably went back to the
source they went back to
with a thousand faces or the hero's
journey they went back to Campbell
himself rather than Campbell as
distilled through other movies and other
people writing about how to write movies
well here's the thing though too is is
that you know that's a more literary
book it's like if they yeah it's more
literary it's a it's a work of
anthropology it's not a lack of how to
do creative writing yeah exactly and so
it's it's thick and like you you got I
want to read it yeah where is so I
imagine you you would get something a
bit more involved a bit more meticulous
and a bit more you know a bit more
worthwhile I guess on the structure
because it's to read that book you know
it's it's an anthropological and it's
you know a thoughtful experience I would
imagine as it's you know it's a
discourse yeah whereas sometimes save
the cat uh you know not to fully be like
new but like sometimes said okay it's a
thin book it's easy to read and it's
basically going if you want to write a
successful Hollywood movie here's how
you do it you know it's like that's not
the attitude that's coming out of or at
least that I get out of here 0 here of a
thousand faces or you know the hero's
journey and that's not even something I
necessarily get out of story or yeah
story feels like I mean there are whole
chapters and story devoted to mold the
idea of multiple different kinds of
plots yeah and I mean and those books
even though they are about structures
even though they are about writing a
script you know that you can that you
can make it something out of they're not
they're still focused on the craft it
feels like whereas save the cat reads
sort of like here's what you need to
know to get the successful movie made
like you know and here's how it works
and all these other movies like it's I
get why it's done so well because it's
more of a marketer's screenwriting book
than it is just about the craft you know
it's like it's not how to make your
craft good it's how to make your craft
work because I ok with that attitude it
feels like save the cat is a book on how
to write written for people who don't
write or necessarily want to go with the
the brain space of writing yeah I mean
it's not a literary book that way this
is more like here's
struction if you can fill it properly
you can write a script like it's not
quite so at least screaming like anyone
can do it but but basically that's what
it's saying is sort of here's the
structure here is how its work in
countless movies and you know you have a
really good chance of getting this old
if you could just follow that structure
you know and I feel like it's kind of
sad and maybe this isn't the case but
you know it feels kind of sad to think
the most marketable book in the book
that pitched it like how to make this
work in quotes you know is the one that
has left its fingerprints so apparently
all over everywhere the ones that are
about well let's think deeply about this
and actually kind of look at the nuance
and how stories have worked in people
over thousands and thousands of years
yeah you know it's it's like even if to
fill this to more of a philosophical
essence rather than like you know a
bullet to a bulleted list yeah or even
just you know it's even in some of the
books that aren't you know quite as
philosophical it's it's still like yeah
maybe put it into this three act
structure with certain designated beats
but here's why and here's the craft of
it all you know um and it it seems like
it comes from a more constructive place
like it's concerned with figuring out
screenwriting whereas this is you know
concerned with figuring out Hollywood
success you know yeah which are
different things yeah and now I'm very
curious to read writing movies for fun
and profit yeah cuz I don't even like
right on the tin it says yeah and I mean
that's I I can imagine there's a certain
it probably will but it's also you know
from guys who know how insidious that
can be new you know um the state hey
yeah yeah you know the promises since
I'm London robert ben garant yeah garand
garant girl but yeah like did I feel
like you can kind of maybe put that
roadblock or that that checkpoint that
bookmark at war save the cat starts to
hit mmm because now we do have a bunch
of the same movie yeah you know and a
bunch of the same trailers for that
movie yeah you know and the cool stuff
is happening
way from that structure they're making
the movie again yeah but I just saw last
week's movie that's basically what it
feels like it feels like you're not
going to the theater and seeing a bunch
of different movies you're going to a
theater and seeing a bunch of different
remakes of the same movie sometimes that
movie has iron man sometimes it has
Batman sometimes sometimes it has liam
neeson sometimes it's in space sometimes
it isn't sometimes it's giant robots it
loves America yeah chants transform you
hey I will say oh yeah I watched all my
movies some of it how was it you know I
quite I got something out of it I don't
know no I had I had it on in my in the
office I was just sort of chilling
watching Shia LaBeouf out of one corner
of my eye I don't know especially when I
got to even stevens this is like you
know just watching a guy wait he was
watching all of you even stevens too did
the movie oh we made it like a TV movie
or something oh it was all it was always
films so like going going from I think
he did something right after fury like
all the way from most recent to first
Wow and yes it's like three straight
days in this new york theatre and just
took a webcam on him in some of the room
as he watched these movies there was
something i found oddly soothing about
just watching i watch and react like you
know there were times when he'd be
falling asleep or there would be times
where you could tell he really wasn't
enjoying the movie he was watching and
then like during even stevens he looked
so happy oh like he was he was laughing
so hard at one point he was like
laughing kind of tearing up and it was
just like oh this is an interesting sort
of thing and like it was so long that it
stopped being I don't know it just it
felt kind of authentic to me like he
actually wanted to be there versus you
know not not like a yeah how do you how
do you look when he was watching
nymphomaniac I didn't see it that early
and first because that was the first day
and I think I caught it part way through
the second okay so I've watched
something that he really wasn't into and
then you know some of the ones were a
little more normal what was he really
not into I well I'm trying to guess cuz
I I only caught up with I only found
like a
a schedule of the movies on the you know
like on the last day but um may have
been like a transformers or something
cuz like in all the write-ups there like
at one point he looks like visibly kind
of like he's not enjoying this at all um
and I know he wasn't I think he left for
an hour during one of the Transformers
movies are shot yeah it was just not
town um I'm sure somebody on the
internet has logged it but I don't I
just I don't know I kind of I kind of
dug that just kind of glanced over at
shy as he's watching some something he
was in you know it was just like I don't
know in a weird way it's like watching a
guy I can see how there might be some
kind of genuine value and like watching
a guy watch himself and sort of like
high existential that must be to watch
yourself get younger on screen and like
how you've been different over the years
and clearly would only have a specific
context to him but like you know there's
something interesting to watch that
context play out in his face you know so
no it's cool yeah four or five yeah
would you recommend it to friends I you
knowed I check it out here's a little
here's what should happen they should he
should have recorded all of all my
movies put out a DVD and then do a
second all my movies where he watches
all my movies it's very I was gonna
piggyback on that night too whimsical in
my mind so all done you've defeated me
yeah you're feeding me with humor round
one viv it Corey vit vivre its glory
this round one well Corey well it's been
a day it's been a dank it's been a dank
we're gonna hopefully have a guest star
on the next dank so so go any of that
put your put your guest pants on yeah
because we got company and we want you
to be walking around in your in your
long johns you know it's cold out there
entertaining yeah we were entertaining
all right and then you know we're not
streaming yest we have a cotillion in
this household that we like to you know
keep on a tight keep on a tight March
there yeah
so it's an odd household we live so from
everyone here at at the dank student at
dank studios i am aaron i am Jerry and
you are amazing and stay dank stay dank
amazing people